[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIT MENNUTI: Hi, everyone.
Thanks so much for
joining us today.
My name is Brit Mennuti.
I'm a Product Manager on
the Google AR VR Team.
I'm joined here today by my
colleague Bruno, a Software
Engineer on the team.
We have an awesome agenda
ahead for you today.
So by the end of
today's session,
you'll have helped
us to demo an AR app.
But before we get
into that, I'll
share a little bit of history
as to how and why we built Poly.
I'll share what Poly is, and
how it can be useful to you
as a developer.
And then I'll pass it off to
Bruno to dive into the Poly API
before we do the demo.
Now, you may be wondering,
what is this Poly thing,
and why should I care about it?
Well, I think the
best way to answer
that question is to take a quick
trip down Poly developer memory
lane.
The team that built
Poly was actually
originally devoted to the
idea of productivity in VR.
It was our goal to make people
more efficient and effective
at work using
immersive technology.
And we had a whole
bunch of hypotheses
about how we could do that.
And we figured, the best way to
validate those hypotheses was
to build a whole
bunch of VR prototypes
and test them with real people.
We built everything, like
organizing your docs in VR,
to training people on
how to use the espresso
machine in our micro kitchen.
But regardless of the
prototype that we built,
one thing was always the same.
We needed 3D models.
And finding the right 3D
model was really, really hard,
especially if we wanted a
lot of 3D models that looked
like they belong together.
So we said to ourselves,
OK, no big deal.
We'll make our own 3D models.
Turns out, making your own 3D
models is also really hard.
In fact, what you see
here on this screen
is a model of a hand created
by a software engineer named
Chris on our team from one of
our virtual meeting prototypes.
Now, how many of
you actually knew
that was a hand
before I told you?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: I did.
BRIT MENNUTI: I don't
believe some of you.
All jokes aside,
this got us thinking
that maybe, creating models
could actually be a lot easier.
And perhaps, VR was
the answer to that.
So we pivoted, and
we built Blocks.
Blocks is an app for the
HTC Vive and Oculus Rift
that lets you create
beautiful 3D models in VR.
And what makes Blocks special
compared to other modeling
applications is
that you actually
inhabit the same space as the
thing that you're modeling.
So instead of
training your brain
to think about a 3D
object on a 2D surface,
you can literally
just walk around it.
Thanks to the launch of Blocks,
that same engineer, Chris,
that I mentioned
earlier was able to make
this beautiful fish tank
model in less than 15 minutes.
He also made this amazing robot
workstation, all in Blocks.
And I don't know
about you, but I
think that that robot hand
looks a little bit better
than the hand I
showed you earlier.
You might have also seen Chris
in some of our launch videos.
That's right, folks.
One day, you, too,
can become famous.
And as we were reflecting on
Blocks, we started to realize,
there are a whole bunch
of other resources
for 3D assets that could be
used in AR and VR development.
For example, Tilt Brush
is another VR app that
lets you paint in 3D space.
You can create everything
from beautiful portraits
to entire 3D
environments, replete with
both audio and visual effects.
And we also knew that there
was this vast community of 3D
modelers out there,
already making
tons of assets that could be
used in AR and VR development.
So we thought to
ourselves, maybe
the problem wasn't that
there wasn't an easy way
to make models.
It was also that there
wasn't a single resource
to find all those assets
to use for development.
And that's why we built Poly.
Poly is a library of 3D
assets and experiences.
And our mission is to organize
the world's 3D information
and make it
accessible to creators
and developers like yourselves.
When you visit Poly,
you'll see thousands
of assets, some of which have
been contributed by Google,
but many more of which
have been uploaded
by a vast community
of 3D modelers
using Blocks, Tilt Brush,
and other modeling apps.
And when you upload
your assets to Poly,
you have the option to make
them what we call remixable.
What this means is that you give
other creators and developers
the right to use your assets
under a Creative Commons
by license.
This means they can
download those assets,
use them in their apps, as long
as they give you attribution.
Well the good news is that over
82% of public assets on Poly
today are actually remixable.
So what this means is,
there are tens of thousands
of assets available
for all of you
to use today for free under
a Creative Commons license.
And when you go to Poly,
you can browse by category.
You can also search for
exactly what you need.
We recently added object
recognition to search.
So you'll find
what you need even
if it isn't manually tagged.
And when you find
the perfect asset,
you can download the file.
We offer downloads in the
form OBJ, and in some cases,
FBX files, as well.
Now, you might be thinking,
this sounds great.
But can I actually find
useful assets on Poly?
Well, let's look
through some examples.
Maybe you need a sandcastle
model for your vacation mode
app.
Or perhaps you want to recreate
Noah's ark in your living room.
Or maybe you've always
wanted to include
a realistic version of your
BFF, Carl, in your next game.
Fun fact-- Carl is
actually a real human.
He's actually one of
the talented designers
behind Blocks and Poly.
Or maybe you're building
an archeology app.
And you need a whole
bunch of real 3D scans
of historic artifacts.
Well, thanks to a
recent partnership
between Google Arts and
Culture and SCI-Arc,
there are a dozen of these
actual artifacts hosted on Poly
for you to download today.
And finally,
perhaps all you ever
wanted was a politically
correct cheeseburger.
That's right, folks.
This burger has the
cheese in both locations.
No matter what
you're looking for,
you'll find everything you need
on Poly to create a unique VR
or AR experience, like
this VR scavenger hunt
game created by artist and
developer Harlan Perez.
He built this using Blocks,
Poly, and Unreal Engine.
Or these AR apps.
On the left, you'll see an app
from developer Andrew Deutsch,
where he takes beautiful
flower models from Poly
and puts them in an
otherwise-dismal New York City
subway platform.
Or on the right, an app from
developer Ben Ferns that uses
object recognition
and the Poly API
to retrieve low-poly versions
of real-world objects
in real time.
Now, as we thought
back to Poly's mission,
it occurred to us that we might
be falling a little bit short
on the accessible portion.
Having to go to a website and
download an object every time
you needed it for
your development
was perhaps not the
most efficient solution.
So that's why we
built the Poly API.
And with that, I'm going to hand
it off to Bruno to share more.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So we're going to talk about
the Poly API and Poly Toolkit.
There are so many ways
that I could begin
a presentation about an API.
So when I asked for
advice, someone said,
why don't you start with
an inspirational quote--
something somebody famous said
that's relevant to the topic?
So this is the one that I chose.
"A good API creates more
problems than it solves."
Does anybody know who
famously said this and when?
That's right-- nobody, ever.
And that's why, any time
you're working with an API,
there is a simple but
fundamental question
that you have to ask.
And that question is, why?
Why would you use this API?
How is my life easier or
better if I use the Poly API?
To answer that, let's go
back a couple of decades.
So I've always liked
building games.
So my friends and I
would get together,
and we would try to
build a bunch of games
in the old computers
of the time.
We kind of knew
how to do the code.
But the problem that we
had was that none of us
really knew how to make art.
We had no skills whatsoever.
Like, stick figures were
already a challenge.
But somehow, we had
very high expectations
about what our graphics
were going to look like.
In reality, however, our
graphics looked more like this.
Does anybody know what that is?
It's a dragon, of course.
But come on.
If this is a valid hand,
then that's a valid dragon.
Now, you might
think that my skills
would have improved over time.
However, you would be wrong.
I'm the kind of developer who
uses cubes for everything.
So with my skill level, I
could theoretically make a game
about a cube that shoots other
cubes to protect the larger
cubes from being hit
by the smaller cubes,
all against a backdrop
of moving cubes.
If you think that there's no
way that that game is viable,
if you think that
there is no way
that that's an
actual thing, it's
because you haven't
played Cubic Pilot.
Not only did I launch
this, but Google,
in some official
capacity, actually
endorsed this, because this is
a sample for the Google Play
Games API.
Now, my point with all this
is that we all have this book
as developers in our shelf.
It's at the top of my shelf.
Everyone has it.
It's a bestseller.
It's called "Apologizing
for the Lack of Graphics."
Now, sometimes, I know,
we can get away with it.
Sometimes, we can do
clever tricks in our games
to make graphics unnecessary.
My favorite one is
claiming that it's magic.
The dragon is invisible.
But it doesn't work every time.
Users end up noticing
that we're doing this.
Now, to some people,
when I show them
this, what they suggest to
me is, why don't you just buy
a collection of 3D assets?
You know, I could just buy a
collection of nice 3D assets,
and then you don't have to use
cubes or ugly dragons anymore.
And then I say, well, this
is the traditional model
for asset acquisition.
This model has a
couple of problems.
One of the problems with this
model is cats, obviously.
Maybe I should go
into more details.
All right, if I
ever actually tried
to buy a 3D model of a cat
online, you know what I mean?
You can't just buy one cat.
You have to buy a super cat pack
deluxe special edition with 700
fully [INAUDIBLE] animated cats.
It's very hard to
find separate assets.
The second problem is
that sometimes, you're
still in the prototyping
phase of your app.
At this point in my
app development cycle,
I'm not even sure if I'm
making a game about cats
or about spaceships, or even
about cats that fly spaceships.
It's a valid thing.
So I need that
flexibility to try it out
with different assets.
And the third problem is users.
Well, as you know,
user are fickle,
and they don't know
what they want.
So what happens if you
ship your app and then--
I know it's unthinkable,
but suppose that you never
actually thought
about cats at all
during the development
cycle of your app.
And now, when it's in the
user's hand at runtime,
the users want to
have a cat in the app.
How do you do that?
Well, you would need
to somehow figure out
a way to pull out a
cat from a runtime API.
So Poly, by contrast,
has the flexibility
that you need to try out
with many different assets
from Poly.
It has a runtime API, which
means that during runtime, you
can go and search for cats and
then present cats to the user,
or anything else that they want.
And also, it's not
a static collection.
It's not something that
you just compile once,
and then you only
have the same assets.
It's a growing
collection, because users
are contributing to that
collection all the time.
If you see there, you're
going to see that even
I, with my limited skills,
made my contribution.
Can you guess which one
is my 3D model over there?
Any guesses?
It's actually none of them.
I uploaded this cube.
So whenever you're making a
game, and you need a cube,
you know where to look.
So we have this great
collection of assets on Poly.
And then, on the other
side, we have our apps.
And we want to be able
to consume those assets.
So what's the missing
piece in that puzzle?
Of course, what we
need in this is an API.
So the API is how your app gets
access to these assets in Poly.
Now, naming is difficult in
general in computer science.
So we put a bunch of
very creative people
together to come up with a
name for this API for Poly.
After several hours, we
came up with Poly API.
It's very precise.
On a very high level,
how does this API work?
it's like a search API.
Your app wants 3D assets.
So it is going to
make a search query.
In the simplest case, that's
going to be a keyword.
For example, the app
could say, I like cats.
I would like some cats, please.
And then the API would
return some interesting cats
for your app to consume.
Now, what happens if
you're not a cat person?
Can you still use this API?
And the answer is yes.
Or what happens if you
want to be much more
specific about the
kinds of animals
that you want in your app?
In that case, you can make
a more complex request.
For example, you could say,
I like low-complexity assets
from the animals category,
made in Tilt Brush.
And I want them to be ordered
from newest to oldest.
So you can make very complex
API requests like that.
You probably would not
get any cats on this one,
because as we know, cats
are very complex animals.
And if the user is
signed in, you also
have the option of getting
the user's own assets.
So this means that
you can get the assets
that the user has uploaded to
Poly, but hasn't published yet.
So you can get assets
in draft state.
And you could use
that, for example,
to let the user add
those to your scene.
So we talked about the what,
and we talked about the why.
Now, let's move on to the next
W question, which is when.
When do we use the Poly API?
Fortunately, the answer to
this one is much easier--
how about now?
So with that, let's
do a live demo.
You know what's the first
rule of live demos on stage?
It's, you never do a
live demo on stage.
So I'm going to try and
see if this will work.
All right, how many
people actually
think that this demo
is going to work?
All right.
How many people think this
demo is going to fail?
All right, a couple of people.
How many people think it's going
to fail in some, like, epic
and embarrassing way?
Like, something is going
to catch fire on stage.
Oh, two people.
That's not bad.
All right, so here,
I have my demo app.
So this is using ARCore and
the Poly Toolkit for Unity.
So first of all, this is just
ARCore showing me the planes
that it's tracking.
So we have here this very nice
carpet that ARCore is tracking.
And now, when I tap my
finger on the screen,
I'm going to place an object.
And this object came
from Poly, but it's
pre-compiled into the app.
It's this little intersection.
Now, since I don't want to
bend down to the ground,
I will just--
I have this hack where I can
increase the height of this--
right here.
OK, oops, it's
running away from me.
There we go.
So we have this
little intersection.
Now, the point of
this app is just
to add some objects
from Poly to make
it look more like a real city.
So what's one
thing that we could
add to make it look more real?
Cars?
BRIT MENNUTI: How
about some cars?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yeah, cars.
Cars make sense.
All right, so I'm going
to do a search query.
I'm just going to type car.
Then we do a search.
I made this keyboard myself.
And now I'm going to do search.
OK, so these are
our search results.
And now, all we have to do
is tap one of these cars.
And now, it's in our scene.
Then I rotate the
car a little bit.
There we go.
And I'm going to carefully place
it here on one of our streets.
There we go.
So I actually put some--
I wrote some scripts in this
so that the cars actually
do something.
So if I click Run,
then the car will run.
And now, let's add
some other cars.
So go back the results.
Let's add this one.
And just going to
place it over here.
You may or may not have
played more exciting games.
But you know, in
some games, your goal
is to save the kingdom,
save the world.
In this game, your
goal is just to make
traffic as bad as possible.
And the other minigame
in this is, how many cars
can I put in the scene without
them crashing into each other?
My high score is one.
Let's see if I
beat my high score.
Wow, my high score is now two.
Let's add something else.
What's something else that you
would see in a typical city?
BRIT MENNUTI: How about a boat?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: A boat.
Sure, why not?
A boat.
After all, this is AR.
Searching for boats,
see what boats we have.
All right, I'm going to
add this cruise liner.
Let's make it a little bigger.
All right, I'm going to put this
cruise liner here on the road.
There we go.
It's going to be driving on
the wrong side of the road,
but I think that's not the
worst traffic violation
that's happening here.
Oh, my high scores is two, now.
Perfect.
So let's add something else.
I mean, we're not restricted
to forms of transportation.
It's getting close to lunch.
So I'm getting hungry.
Let's just add a jar of peanut
butter, or something like that.
I'm just making this up as I go.
So jar-- oh, even better.
All right, let's put this year.
It's a giant jar of jam.
Does anybody know what this is?
Any guesses?
It's a traffic jam, exactly.
It's a terrible pun.
Sorry.
There we go.
So this just shows how you
can continually add objects
from Poly into this demo.
And I think pretty much, I
think, nothing else surprising
is going to happen in this
demo, unless, of course,
a dragon were to appear
and set fire to everything.
So for those of you who
thought that something
was going to catch fire, I
think you were right, in a way.
All right, so I'm glad
that this demo worked.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
All right, now let's move on to,
how do I actually use the API?
So you have the Poly
API on one side.
And you have your app
on the other side.
And it's naturally
cross-platform,
because it's a REST API.
This means that
you can get access
to it from any device that
has access to the internet.
So we support
several platforms--
Android, iOS,
Unity, Unreal, Web.
Today, we're going to
focus our attention
on the Poly Toolkit for Unity.
So Poly Toolkit is
just an SDK for Unity
that lets you use the Poly API.
So when you download and
install Poly Toolkit,
it becomes fully integrated
into your Unity editor.
So you're going to
see that window.
And on that window, we can
browse for Poly assets.
So I can see, that's
going to show you--
by default, it's going to
show you the featured ones
on the website.
But you can change the filters.
So you could filter
by object type.
You could filter by category.
You could say, let me look
at the stuff in the transport
category, the food category.
You could also do a search.
So there's a little
search button there.
So if you need a
dragon for your app,
you can search for a dragon.
If you need a cube, if you
need a cat, anything you want,
just click search.
And then you'll find
the asset that you want.
Then, once you find
some good asset
that you want to important into
your scene, all you have to do
is click on the Import button.
For example, I just click
on the Import button,
and now this garden
is on my scene.
And notice that this is already
in your scene, in your project.
And this is already a
perfectly reasonable app.
If you click Play,
it's going to run.
And it's already
like a full app.
Of course, if you actually want
the garden to do something,
you have to write some code.
Otherwise, it's going
to be more like one
of those contemplative gardens.
But you know what's
going to happen?
You're going to ship this
app, contemplative garden,
on Google Play.
And then the first thing
that users are going to do
is, they're going to say, sure.
This garden's very nice.
However, I want a cat.
That's what's going to happen.
So to get the users their cat,
you have to use the Poly API.
You have to use the runtime
part of the Poly API.
So let's talk a little
bit about the Runtime API.
It allows you to browse,
search, and download assets
at runtime from your app.
I have no idea what that
blue robot is doing.
This is an actual picture
from what's going on
in the data center right now.
So this is an overview of
how the Runtime API works.
First, we have to
create a Request object.
For example, you could
create-- the most typical one
would be the
PolyListAssetsRequest.
This Request object just
encodes your search query.
Then, you pass that object
to one of the API methods--
for example, ListAssets.
ListAssets just means, I
want to list the assets that
match that search request.
Then, you're going to
wait for the callback.
And the callback
is going to have
the results for your search.
And then, based on
that search, you
have to figure out
which ones you want.
If there are
several matches, you
have to figure out which one
you actually want to import.
And then lastly, you
call PolyApi.Import
to import that into your scene.
Start with a basic example.
If you just do
PolyListAssetsRequest.Featured,
this is a default
featured query.
This means, you want to get
exactly what Poly is currently
showing on the website.
So featured assets,
no specific category,
and no specific keyword--
just anything good
that Poly is currently
showing on the website.
Then you execute that request.
To do that, just
call ListAssets.
You'll pass your request.
And then once you
get a callback,
you're going to get a list
of assets that you want.
And then you're going to choose
among those assets in some way.
For example, you could just
let the user pick one of them.
And then, once you know
which one you want to import,
you just call PolyApi.Import
and pass in the asset,
and that's going to get
imported into your scene.
So now, suppose that you
want to do a keyword search.
In our example, we want cats.
To do that, you simply
just set the keywords field
of the request to cat.
And that's it.
Then you execute the request,
and then you get cats.
Now, by default, you're
going to get assets
from newest to latest, which is
normally a good sorting order.
But what if you want--
what if I don't want new cats?
I want the best cats.
In that case, you just
set this sorting order
to PolyOrderBy.BEST.
And then you get from the
best cat to the worst cat.
What happens if you are
more picky about the cats
that you want?
Well, we can fill
in other fields.
For example, we could specify
the maximum complexity field
and say, I want
medium-complexity cats at most.
Complexity just means
the polygon complexity
of the model.
So if you're running an app
in a performance-sensitive
environment, you might just
want the low-complexity models.
If you're not particularly
strained about performance,
you could ask for
high-complexity models
that are more realistic.
You can also set
the format filter.
And you can request,
how many cats per page
do you actually want?
So again, it's getting
close to lunch time.
We're getting hungry.
So of course, the Poly API
has a solution for that.
You can request anything
from our food category
by using an API call.
So if you set the
category to food,
then you're going
to get everything
from the food category.
And since we're
really hungry, let's
just set the page size to 100.
So we want 100 items
of food at a time.
And now, the default
ordering is newest to oldest.
So chances are, if you
run this query right now,
you're going to get a freshly
uploaded batch of cookies,
which is nice.
What happens if you're
worried about the quality
of the assets?
Maybe I don't want to serve
just any cookies that anybody
has uploaded into the site.
I want to have some criteria.
So you could just hire a team
and have a team whose only
job it is to search for
assets and mark the ones that
are good, that you want
to present to your user,
and the ones that are not.
But we already had to do that
work, because that's what
we do for the Poly website.
So we decided to expose that in
the API to make things easier.
So we have a flag
called curation status.
And you can use that
in your search query.
This means that whatever
asset has that set to true,
it means that we--
that our human reviewers
actually marked that
as being a good asset.
So if you trust our
good taste, then you
can use that flag to filter
your assets, as well.
In terms of code, all you
have to do is set curated
equals true.
And that will filter only
by the reviewed assets.
Now, we're going to have
a good problem to solve,
which is, you run the query.
And now, we have a bunch
of choices for the user.
We have a bunch of cats
that they can choose from.
So how do you actually let
them pick a cat, or a dragon,
or a car, or anything
else that they search for?
Well, you could, in theory,
just download all the models,
import them into Unity
objects, and then show them
to the user, right?
But this might be wasteful,
because you might actually
spend a lot of memory and a
lot of time downloading those.
And then the user's
just going to pick one
and then never look
at the other cats.
So what's a more
economical way to do this?
Well, we have thumbnails.
So the API allows you
to download thumbnails
for any assets in our API.
So for example, if you have an
asset from a ListAssets result,
and you want a thumbnail
for it to show to the user,
all they have to do is call
the FetchThumbnail API call.
And then, you're going
to get a callback
with a Unity Texture2D
that represents
a thumbnail for that asset.
You can do anything
with that texture.
You could map it to an
object, or you could just
convert it into a sprite and
then display it on the screen.
This is what we do in
our demo when we're
showing the possible cars.
So these are not
the actual models.
What I'm doing is, I'm showing
the thumbnails for the models.
And once the user actually
clicks one of them,
and I am reasonably
sure that the user wants
that car, that's when I
actually import the model.
Speaking of placing
objects, what
happens if you just place
an object in the world?
Well, if this was a traditional
app, that's fine, right?
The object is
there on the scene.
That's what you want.
But however, you're
working in AR,
you need to make sure that
that object is anchored
to some real-world surface.
Does anybody know what
you can use to do this?
ARCore anchors, yes, exactly.
How did you know?
So that's when the
anchors come in handy.
So when ARCore detects
a stable surface,
it's going to report the--
it's going to report the
surface to you through the API.
If you want to add an object
so that it's firmly placed
on that surface, you use what
is called an anchor object.
So what you do is, you
import the object from Poly.
And then you set its parent
to the anchor object.
So that means that the
object will remain stable
on that table.
Even if you move
the phone around,
if you change the
orientation of the phone,
it's going to be firmly
placed on that tabletop.
Even if ARCore improves its
understanding of the scene,
it's going to remain there.
So how do you
accomplish this in code?
Well after you import an
asset, what you do is,
you set the active
member to false.
This is going to make it so
that the object is invisible
before the user places it.
And then, presumably,
you're going
to show some UI
for the user that's
going to say, well,
tap the screen
somewhere to place this object.
Once the user touches the
screen to place the object,
then you do a ray cast to
figure out where the user hit.
And when you do a ray
cast, you can figure out
exactly what the pose
of the ray cast hit is.
And that's what you use
to create the anchor.
Once you have that,
you create the anchor.
And then finally, you're going
to set the object's visibility
property to true so that
the object begins to render.
And that's all there is to it.
Just import from
Poly, set the anchor,
and now you have this
object in your AR scene.
And Poly Toolkit has a
lot of other features
that we're not going to cover.
So it does automatic
rescaling of objects for you.
It can convert units.
So if your scene
is in centimeters,
and the object is in meters,
it's going to convert.
And it can get the
featured assets.
It can get the
user's own assets.
It can get even the assets
that the user has liked.
You can change the
material assignments
if you have a different
look for your app,
and you need specific materials.
We can eve do automatic
attribution generation,
so we don't have to keep
track of which objects
we downloaded from where.
We just automatically generate
a copyright file that you
can display in your app.
So let's talk a little bit about
what goes on behind the scenes.
So this is the part that you
don't have to worry about.
This is what Poly
Toolkit does for you.
So what's the difference
between the two foxes--
the fox on the left and
the fox on the right?
Well, clearly, the fox on the
right is sitting down, right?
And the other difference between
these is that one is a model
and one is data.
So a model is a
collection of polygons
that you want to
render on your scene.
And data is just characters.
The data represents the model.
Now, Poly API, of course,
only outputs data.
And what Poly Toolkit
does is convert that data
into Unity models.
For that, we need to
establish a format.
This is one of those things that
could be easy, but in reality,
is not, because
apparently, nobody
agrees on how to do this.
This is a partial list of
3D formats from Wikipedia.
Now, we have to start somewhere.
So we decided to start off
with the most basic one, OBJ.
So OBJ is a great format.
And it has everything
that you're ever
going to need for 3D
objects if it's 1995.
For today's standards, it's
a little underspecified.
It has a bunch of nonstandard
extensions, limited material
support.
However, it is widely supported.
So we do offer that
format in the API.
Now, to be a little more modern.
We have glTF.
glTF is more modern.
It's display optimized.
It has an ample expressiveness.
So it can display--
I mean, it can encode scenes,
nodes, animations, materials.
And best of all, it's a format
that gets everything right.
It's stable, it's
future proof, and it's
unlikely to change
in the near future.
Just kidding.
It's changed.
However, glTF 2 gets
everything right
and is unlikely to change
in the near future.
So in practice in
the Poly API, we
offer objects both
in the OBJ format
and in the glTF 2 format.
So if you're consuming
the Poly API directly,
you can choose
which one you want.
So you can choose OBJ.
You can choose glTF 2.
And Poly Toolkit uses glTF 2 and
imports that as Unity objects,
doing everything automatically,
including material mapping
and material generation.
All right, so we talked
about Poly Toolkit for Unity.
There's also Poly
Toolkit for Unreal.
And if you're developing a
native app on Android iOS
or Web, we do also have
samples on our site
showing how to integrate
with the Poly API
on those platforms.
So if you're developing,
for example, for Unreal,
this is an example of
Poly Toolkit for Unreal.
It's the same principle
as the one for Unity.
It's a fully
integrated environment
where you can download and then
use Poly assets in your scene.
If you're developing
for Android,
there's a sample that shows
you how to include assets
from Poly into an--
into a little,
very simple AR app,
where you just tap the
screen, and then you
can include a specific
Poly object on your scene.
If you're using Web,
there's also a sample.
And this sample uses three.js.
This is actually
the easiest one,
because our Poly website is
also built using three.js.
And as a fun fact, the
guy who created three.js
is the one who wrote the sample.
So this just shows the
wide variety of experiences
that you can build
with the Poly API.
For example, you're not
restricted to just AR.
This is not just an AR toolkit.
You can also build VR apps.
You can build
traditional 3D apps.
This is an example of a
simple escape room app,
a VR app that we made in the
office a couple of months ago,
just to show--
I mean, just to try out what
we could do with the Poly API
and with Poly objects.
One thing that you
notice is that even
though different people
created the different objects
in that scene, they somehow
look nicely together.
They look like they
belong to the same scene.
And we also added some
lighting for an extra effect.
And we got that cheesy, spooky
atmosphere that we wanted.
The puzzles aren't
particularly hard.
And I think I just spoiled
the game for everybody,
because now you know that
the access code is 714.
Fun fact, when we
actually tried to play
this game in the
office, the first person
that we gave it to, they
just put the headset on,
and we said, you have to
manage to find a way to escape
the room through that door.
What they immediately
did is, they
just walked through the
door and won the game,
because what's to stop them?
And then we had to be more
specific for the second user.
So you actually have to
solve our puzzles before you
walk through that door.
That just shows you some
of the design problems.
Well, for me, of
course, what it means
is that I can stop
using assets like that
and maybe upgrade my assets
to look more like that.
Now, I'm not exactly
a dragon expert,
but I can sense that there
was some improvement in dragon
quality there.
So if you're interested
in trying out the Poly API
and building applications with
Poly, please visit our site.
So poly.google.com is
the 3D gallery site
where you can browse assets.
developers.google.com/poly
is a developer site where
you're going to find everything
you need to start developing
with Poly today,
including all the SDKs,
including the samples,
documentation,
and everything
else that you need.
So thank you very much.
And we want to hear from you.
So if you liked the session,
please fill in the survey.
If you didn't like the session,
the survey is optional.
[LAUGHTER]
And that's it.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]